hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round three of this
year's video World Cup it is pregnant
versus David Navara uh number one check
Grandmaster and uh well if you if you
had to choose one of them to win this it
would be very hard to do so because
pragnan and um is is incredible but he
is very young and he's even higher rated
he's won uh rating Point high rated the
Navid Navara but for those of you who
know David Nevada know that he is an
exceptional Grandmaster he has so much
experience and uh well it could be just
anyone's uh anyone's match and anyone's
game this is the first game of the match
will be we'll be showing uh pregnant
that defeated very strong French Grand
Master Maxim Lagarde to qualify into
round three he skipped round one because
he is in the top 50 and everyone who is
in the top 15 defeated World Cups is
seated directly into round two and so
has Navara he skipped round one in round
two he defeated Nicholas of Germany and
now they face each other so let's check
it out and if in case you're wondering
why I'm using my old setup instead of
the new one I'm traveling for a couple
of days now I'm using my laptop and I
forgot to upload the new interface I
know it's silly mistake but what are you
gonna do so let's check it out the proc
has the white pieces and he opens with
Ponte E4 sorry about that
we have Pawn to E5 by David Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to C4 we
have Bishop to C5 and of course I know
what you guys are wondering but no it
was not played here we have Pawn to D3
by Prague the main line of the Joko
pianissimo we have Knight to F6 and now
there are so many moves you can play
here C3 the top move then you can cast
all night to see the reason we'll Bishop
to G5 is the move any move is a move
here but Prague plays Pawn to A4 it's
actually the 10th most popular move in
this position and okay you don't go for
the events but you are trying very hard
to surprise your opponent and catch him
off guard so A4 and Navara goes for
Ponte H6 with castles and now Pawn to D6
there is a game where castles was played
with faunted B6 is a new moon so already
as of move six we have a completely new
game imagine that uh we have Bishop to
E3 now challenging the bishop here and
we have a trade captures captures this
gives a product a semi-open f file for
his Rook but it also gives him a double
epon we have castles and pawn the H3 now
hindering the development of the dark
Square Bishop with Bishop to E6 and now
a similar trade to the dark Square
Bishop's Bishop captures an E6 and pawn
captures creating a very very
symmetrical setup we have Pawn to C3 and
now Pawn to D5 your opponent didn't
prevent it so you might as well strike
in the center we have Knight beat the D2
Pawn to A5 now stopping B4 as one always
should and now Queen to B3 putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn but it's not
really a pawn you care about so Queen to
D6 of course none of you are thinking
about capturing the pawn if you capture
the pawn Rook after B8 traps the White
Queen so I know none of you were
considering that so e captures on D5 we
have Queen captures offering a queen
trade and while uh Prague does want to
trade he wants to trade on his own terms
so he plays Pawn to E4 now inviting
Queen captures on B3 you could also play
Queen captures on D3 and it it kind of
looks great because you well sort of
mess up a white strong Center but then
comes Rook a the E1 and white just has a
whole lot of development for this spawn
and well obviously proc prepared it so
David did not want to go into this and
the engine agrees with uh Davidian says
okay you could capture on D3 but maybe
capturing on B3 is the way to go so he
does Queen capture some B3 Knight
captures and now Pawn to B6 not allowing
the knight uh any any squares from B3
King to F2 the Queens are off the board
and now the king belongs on E3 to guard
the D3 Pawn we have Rook a d8 and now
Rook 8 to D1 Rook to F7 with ideas of
maybe doubling up on the f file or on
the D file we have King to E3 and now
Knight to H5 we have Rook to F2 you know
the Knight might come to G3 so The Rook
on F1 is definitely a liability Knight
to F4 and now you want to kick away the
Knight with G3 but then the H Pawn would
hang so Pawn to H3 with King to f8 and
now Pawn to G3 and Knight back to H5
interestingly you could even play nice
stage 3 such as silly Square to put the
Knight on because it kinda gets trapped
after Rook to H2 but look at this Pawn
to G5 and now if you capture the Knight
then G4 attacks The Rook end the Knight
here problem is although this looks very
nice the problem is captures uh sorry uh
obviously Knight characters and G5 and
now after Knight characters in age
captures you can just play Rook dth one
double up on the H file and the white
gets a better position with the black uh
not really gaining anything for his
fancy moves so a nice Stage 5 instead
going back with Rook to G1 defending the
G3 pawn and King to E7 Navara just
centralizes his Queen we have Knight the
E1 and now Rook captures an F2 so a pair
of Rooks gets traded off the board Rook
characters King characters luckily or
Knight is guarding the D3 pawn and now
Knight back the ba re-maneuvering the
Knight we have King to E3 and now Knight
to D7 so there are four Knights still in
the game obviously there will be a lot
of horsing around Knight to F3 uh we
have Knight H to F6 and now Pawn to G4
preparing Pawn to G5 so Knights the E8
and of course Pawn H5 now uh really
taking control over those light squares
and you might have some ideas of knights
the H4 Knights the G6 is going to be an
excellent Square for the night so Knight
to D6 we have Knight beta D2
and Rook the G8 with Knight to H4 now
eyeing that G6 square but of course
David does not allow that Knight to fade
and here we have a sort of a repetition
Knight h2f3 Knight to D7 Pro goes back
David goes back Prague goes back but not
now because if you went back you would
have a three-fold repetition and it
would be a draw and since uh Prague only
gets the white pieces once next time
he's going to be black against David uh
he wants this game to continue Rook to
F1 and now Pawn to G5 squeeze the
position as much as possible so now
David is saying all right you either
move the Knight or you capture alpassan
uh there's really nothing else to
consider and if you go back then I no
longer have to worry about you
infiltrating anywhere on the king side
so Prague does capture Alpha Song H
captors and G6 Knight captures and now
he just goes back Knight H to F3 uh we
have rooked h8 now preparing to the
Breakthrough and then you've pretty much
taken care of the king side completely
Rook HD Rook to H1 and now King to F6 we
have rooked the H5 putting pressure on
the D5 Pawn but it is very nicely
defended so you don't have to worry
Knight to F7 and now Knight to C for
adding even more pressure to this Pawn
but again it's defended three times so
you don't have to worry Rook to d8 now
put pressure on the D Pawn if the king
ever moves you're gonna capture it and
now comes Rook to H2 sort of um maybe
with an idea of going Rook to D2 maybe
advancing the d-pawn uh but then you
weaken the E4 pawn and you've um you
just give black the opportunity to
undouble his spawn so basically uh
Prague does not have a move here he can
play B3 it's a useful move and also
maybe Rook H5 rookies to rockitch five
Rook H2 it's hard to find a viable plan
here for white uh unless David makes a
mistake and that's exactly what happened
here he played Knight the G5 he offered
a trade of knights and uh the problem is
this move completely loses the game so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Prague while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh brilliant maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight F captures on E5 that's the
good stuff even though the square is
defended twice uh doesn't really matter
and for those of you who were wondering
what about Rook captures on H6 uh not
the best because Knight captures an F3
King characters and not just King G7
attacking the rook and also your D3 Pawn
is still hanging so that's the problem
you're gonna defend the road but then
we'll capture us on D3 with check equal
material black Rook is very active uh
this is a a draw at least so instead
Knight F characters on E5 and now look
at this Knight captures on E5 and now
Rook to F2 with check that's the that's
the move the problem again with Rook
captures on H6 is this Knight on G5 it's
it almost works if you were wondering
King G7 Knight captures on E5 King
characters and now if Knight to F7 Fork
uh Forks the king and the queen you know
it Forks The King The Rook ended the
Knight it's like the meme and then it
goes like and then the night but okay
Knight captures on E5 we have Rook to F2
with check Knight E to F3 now blocking
and of course you don't just give up The
Rook for two nights you just attack the
Knight one more time Knight to D2 Rook
to G8 and now you just uh trade
everything off and you're up a clean
Pawn Knight captures Knight captures
Rook captures with check King to G5 and
now Rook to F7 offering to trade the G
Pawn for the C7 pawn and okay you could
uh uh decide to go one way or the other
but uh both uh ideas are lost for black
so it doesn't really matter I'm just
gonna quickly show what happens if you
capture on G4 Rook captures on C7 and
okay let's say we start advancing the
pawn it looks like okay how are you ever
stopping this Pawn well you don't that's
the point Rook C6 you're gonna create
your own past Pawn through captors on
h6h3 Rook to H6 and once you advance the
pawn you will start to advance your own
pawns H2 D5 and now finally after King
to G2 you're gonna capture it real
captures on each do or wait until it
gets promoted it doesn't really matter
King captures E5 and the two connected
pass pawns will overpower the lonely
Rook here the king is far too behind to
help out with that so I have to Rook to
F7 C5 was played
and not allowing root captures on C7 but
again it doesn't matter Rook to B7 with
King characters and G for now and Rook
captures on B6 with font H5 the passport
now starts marching forward Rook
captures on H6 an E6 Pawn to H4 Rook to
H6 with Pawn to H3 and now Pawn to E5
and now we have rooked the B8 if you go
for King to G3 and try to promote the
pawn then it's the same idea we just
sacrificed the rook and everything is
the same so Rook to B8 was played but
now King to E4 we have Rook capture some
B2 Ponte E6 and now Rook the E2 with
check King to D5 now you're gonna
eliminate the C5 pawn and then you have
three connected pass Pawns in the middle
of the board rookie three and now even
Pawn to D4 giving up the C3 Pawn Rook
captures now you're gonna undouble your
pawns
um but it doesn't no not a double but I
break up your pawns but it doesn't
really matter Rook to D3 check was
played King to C4 and now Rook the E3
Pawn to see C6 now we have kinked the G5
attacking The Rook but now Pawn to C7
offering a rook for uh the the ability
to Queen and see it but of course you
don't do this so Rook the E1 was played
trying to pick up the pawn with Rook to
C1 check followed by Rook captures on C7
but now comes Rook captures on H3 and it
was in this position on move 60 that
David Navara resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here next
move Prague will get a queen into the
game and also if you give a check then
Rook to C3 just blocks check there's no
way to get to the C7 Pawn next move Pro
gets a queen and that's pretty much it
so absolutely absolutely incredible by
Prague it was it was a very tough game
but proc took that one opportunity that
that Navara gave him like I said there's
really not much to do here we can play
B3 that's a useful move if you can
prepare D4 who knows but basically just
repeating is what you would do probably
Prague wouldn't repeat he would find
some way to continue the game he has the
white pieces he wants to push on how he
would do it I have no idea but he manage
the trick David here he went for the
pawn and that's pretty much pretty much
it very very tricky stuff by by Prague
in game two of their match it was a draw
it was a very crazy game David went for
the attack Prague retaliated by also
going for the attack was a pretty crazy
game ended in a draw which means um
goes into the the next round so now uh
we go into the final 32 so 16 pairs of
players these are the pairs uh I'm sure
you guys are interested who is playing
against who so let's check it out Magnus
will be facing Vincent kaimer as
wahapsana will be facing Vaseline
Erasmus will be facing Wang Hao uh
Google will be facing andreasipenko it
will be swedler against
tabassovana Duda versus Maxwell versus
Dominguez Wesley so versus Alexis Arana
grandelius versus Latasha Santos we have
a cindaro versus Arjun irrigation versus
ponomario and Nakamura will be facing so
after this a very tough match against
David Navara Prague goes on to face the
the speed demon himself Hikaru Nakamura
so yeah that's the game really hope uh
really hope you guys enjoyed it um
uh I would like to thank Erin is the
best wife uh no Laura is the best wife
Corrine is the best wife in the entire
universe period Yoon Yang and Mustafa
Mirza for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on this wonderful
event until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day remember
today is the rest day no games will be
played in the World Cup so if you have
any other suggestions do let me know in
the comments see you soon